- So let's talk about
something serious though,
this is amazing.
So Six Degrees, your organization-
- Yep.
- We did something earlier today,
but talk about, what's the purpose?
Why did you wanna do this?
- Well Sixdegrees.org is
a charitable organization
we started in 2017.
And this 2024 is the 40th anniversary
of a certain movie that I did-
- Where there might
have been some dancing.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- There might have been
barn dancing going on.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so we launched this
initiative to build 40,000 kits,
and these are kits that are in bags
or backpacks that get
distributed to people
that need essential items.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Whether they be not doing well,
struggling, unhoused,
whatever it happens to be.
Children sometimes who can't afford them
or going off to school.
So today, with your beautiful crowd,
we actually built 200 bags.
- Super cool man.
Yeah, and let's talk about your podcast.
So this is Six Degrees
with Kevin Bacon, right?
- [Kevin] Yeah.
- [Kelly] What do y'all talk about?
- It's a podcast where
in the first half of it
I discuss with celebrities,
whether they are actors or musicians,
dancers, people from sports,
reality television, comedians.
We just kind of shoot the breeze,
we talk about whatever
connections we might have,
either in terms of having
worked together or whatever.
And the second half of it is
we talk about the organizations
that they are connected to.
Either they're on the board
or it's a foundation that
they've actually started.
And we bring the person on to the podcast
who runs their foundation so
that they get a microphone
in front of them, someone that doesn't-
- [Kelly] Get the spotlight.
- Get the spotlight, yeah.
And so it's a lot about
bringing some attention to things
that celebrities care about
other than the clothes that they wear
or the restaurants that they go to.
- Yeah.
Speaking of good causes,
tomorrow is Giving Tuesday, everybody.
A movement that encourages people
and organizations to positively transform
communities around the world.
We can do it.
So Building Kits by Kevin Bacon campaign.
So how can people get involved
other than showing up
to be an audience member at my show?
- Well that's a great start.
There's a few different ways.
One is that if you have an organization,
wherever it is in the country,
that has a need, even
during this bag building
someone reached out to
our Six Degrees person,
and said "I got an organization in Seattle
"that could really use
something like this going on."
- Yeah.
- So that's one way you
can go to SixDegrees.org,
and connect with us that way.
You can also donate for sure.
We need to raise money-
- [Kelly] To buy the essentials.
- To buy the essentials, to buy the bags.
We do have as many corporate sponsorships
and partnerships as we possibly can.
You know, the Bomba socks
today came from Bomba.
- I love Bomba.
- For instance.
And the third way is in your communities
if you hear about this going on
to just volunteer.
And it doesn't cost you anything,
you show up, you take the things,
you put 'em in the bag,
and it's a great sense of satisfaction
that you feel when you...
My brother and I were down in D.C.
playing a Bacon Brothers Show,
and we showed up, it took us
whatever, an hour of our day
where we're sitting around
waiting for sound check
to just go and hang out with some people,
and put some stuff in some bags,
and then the satisfaction
of turning around,
and seeing 300 bags that
are gonna go to kids
that are struggling in the D.C. area.
It's a great feeling.
- Absolutely.
Well, as we mentioned
earlier before the show
our audience, Kevin and I all got together
to help out with his
Building Kits Campaign,
so here's how that went.
(gentle music)
(crowd cheers)
I'm excited.
- Thank you so much for doing this, Kelly.
- [Kelly] I think this is
the coolest thing ever.
We're building things, right?
- [Kevin] Yeah, we're building bags.
- [Producer] So they
don't know you're coming.
- Well they do now.
Woo.
(crowd cheering)
We're so stoked you're here.
We're excited for the show obviously too,
but I'm super excited, I
never got to do anything
like this yet, so I'm excited.
This was all Kevin's idea, by the way.
It's amazing 'cause he had this idea
for us to pack bags,
like all the essentials,
like toothpaste, deodorant,
and we had the audience,
we already have all these people here.
What's up everybody?
- [Kevin] Something like
this Is very, very simple,
and it is-
- But effective.
- Effective, yeah.
And it brings people together.
- Everybody, you just put one thing
from each basket, right?
- Yep.
One thing from each basket.
- Look at you right now.
- They're all essential
things that people need.
- I was one that needed
help when I was younger.
- Oh.
- So we needed the help,
we needed the essentials,
we needed all that stuff.
- This is awesome.
- Why don't you guys come down this side,
and then we can just
make an assembly line,
and just pass them down.
- Oh yeah.
Y'all come down this way.
Here, I'll go down here.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
We've also put in a handwritten note
of any kind of inspiration that-
- Okay.
- You can find.
- I love this.
I do this for the guests.
- Just hang in there.
- When our recipients receive these gifts
with a handwritten note from
the person that packed them
that shows them that somebody
really cares, it's powerful.
It reminds the recipient
that there's a real person
on the other side of those kits.
- It's just another detail for people
who are maybe just having a rough day
or rough time in their life.
- Hey guys, thank you so much.
This was all Kevin,
he was the one who came up with this.
(crowd cheers)
Thank you for being a
part of it this morning.
- Thank you all so much.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you for your work.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- All right, so let's
talk to some of the people
who helped do the bags this morning.
I'm gonna start with Britney.
So, Britney, what was the
experience like for you?
- Well, Kelly, I really enjoyed
working with you and Kevin this morning
building the bags.
As a military spouse we
just love coming together
for one mission for Giving Tuesday,
to intentionally give back
and connect our communities.
My favorite part of this morning
was adding the person note in there
to really make it add that personal touch.
Mine said "You matter" on it,
and I feel like something simple
is good.
- Absolutely.
Thank you for your family's
service, that's amazing,
thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, Britney.
Theresa also wanted to
share her experience,
so, Theresa, why don't you
tell us what it was like.
- So the experience by far was
very welcoming and warming.
This really resonated with me.
Growing up I was in a
single parent household,
and we also depended on charity
and donations and (indistinct)
and all that.
And one of the things
that I really liked was the comment card
because we can give and we can receive,
but words of wisdom,
just writing something
and saying "Keep the faith,
"everything's gonna be okay,
"God's with you."
- Encouragement, yeah.
- And the encouragement
goes further sometimes
than just actually
receiving a pair of socks.
- Yeah, somebody took
the time to write it.
- [Theresa] Exactly.
- It's not an email or anything
like that, it's personal.
- Exactly.
Coming here was just amazing.
- That's so funny you pointed it out,
but I feel like it is a lot of people,
when you grow up without
then you know what that's like.
- [Theresa] Exactly.
- So when you're blessed then you know
that you need to give
because you were that person
on the other side.
- Exactly.
- I mean it's kind of odd,
but I'm almost really thankful for it
because I understand the need.
So it's really important thing
that not everybody gets,
which you're kind of happy about,
but then you're also like
hey, think outside yourself.
(Kelly laughs)
Before we get to break,
can you tell me what was
going on in that podcast clip?
You wife was in it.
- Yeah, that was kind of a special episode
where she was the guest,
and we highlighted
actually our foundation,
Sixdegrees.org-
- [Kelly] Together.
- And Stacy Houston who runs
the foundation was there.
And it was fun to...
It was unusual to-
- Have you ever interviewed her?
- No, no, I have not.
- Yeah.
- No, I mean unless we're
talking about breakfast.
- But I didn't know if a magazine ever...
You know how sometimes they have stars
interview stars?
I didn't know if they'd ever done that.
- I don't think so.
No, I don't think they've
ever asked us to do that.
And we don't do that
much together, frankly.
I mean we do everything together,
but we don't-
- I appreciate that though.
You have your separate lives, that's cool.
That's important.
That's why you're still married.
- Maybe, yeah.
(audience laughing)
Maybe, yeah.
- Independence.
(audience applauding)
Well, let's take a short break everybody.
Let's check out Kevin's podcast,
Six Degrees with Kevin Bacon
wherever you get your podcasts,
and go online to find out how
you can join Kevin and Six
Degrees in their campaign
to provide 40,000 essential care kits.